negotiators from Russia and Ukraine have
failed to agree on a new long-term
natural gas transit contract and fears
are growing in Europe that it could be a
cold winter Russian gas bound for the EU
is currently pumped through Ukraine and
disagreements over payments have marred
relations between Russia and Ukraine
even going so far as to freeze gas
deliveries before Western Europe is
dependent on Russian gas so are the
transit countries through which they
Russian pipelines pass but the new
undersea North stream to pipeline
bypasses countries like Ukraine and
changes the game completely Russia can
now effectively weaponize the pipeline
by cutting off supplies to countries
like Ukraine while keeping Western
European customers supplied this is the
end of a very long pipeline 200,000
steel tubes running twelve hundred and
thirty kilometers under the Baltic Sea
the energy mega project Nord Stream 2 is
almost complete
Russia says the old pipelines that
brought its gas to Western Europe have
reached their capacity limit Nord Stream
2 adds two more lines but it also makes
Russia far less dependent on the
pipeline's that crossed Ukrainian
territory and that makes Ukraine nervous
it needs gas
but relations between the two countries
are bitter Russia's existing gas
contracts with Ukraine expire at the end
of the year and with Nord Stream 2
coming online it's in no hurry to renew
them the EU has tried to mediate in vain
the time is flying and given the date
varies and there must be a clear sense
of urgency
therefore I appeal to everyone around
the table to be as constructive as
possible unfortunately I have to say
that I'm disappointed by today's outcome
and I say this very openly Moscow has so
far rejected the European Commission's
proposals Russia hopes Nordstrom too
will soon give it a direct route to gas
markets in Western Europe while freezing
out Ukraine
let's go straight to our correspondent
band Riegert in Brussels who's following
those talks but what is Europe trying to
gain there with these talks Europe in
particular well the main goal of the EU
is of course security of supply for
Europe itself the the U does not want
any disruption of gas supplies from
Russia ten years ago the EU experienced
a short disruptions of four weeks but
also you have to say that that the gas
storage facilities in western New York
are completely full right now so Europe
could bridge a disruption of about two
or three months quite easily
why is Europe so depended on Russian gas
in the first place well that's dependent
on nature because Russia is the main
source of natural gas in the world it
still has the biggest gas reserves it's
close
geographically speaking to Europe so
it's it's a natural gas supplier for
Europe and this is history of gas supply
goes far back to the Soviet Union
it was always Russia that supplied West
in Europe and also Germany for example
with most of its gas well isn't Europe
sort of under Russia's thumb there in a
way in a way Kim can Russia blackmail
Europe of a political issue save Ukraine
for example well that would be difficult
for Russia because Russia is also
dependent on Europe and also on the
customers Russia has to sell its gas 60
to 70 percent of the budget of the
federal state budget in Russia are
dependent on the revenues from gas so
they have to sell and Europe has to buy
it's a double dependency it's another
story for Ukraine Ukraine is not buying
gas anymore from Russia it's it's now
getting its gas actually from Western
Europe but Ukraine is dependent on the
fees it charges for gas transport via
the pipe lines running through Ukraine
Russia wants to get rid of these fees
and the dependency on Ukraine and
therefore is building these new
pipelines around Ukraine a Turk stream
in the south and north stream in the
north battery got thank you very much